[Music]
Oh daddy from the legatus
[Music]
I'm a fair night along with you
[Music]
[Music]
rape is used in my country as a weapon
against those who only will only want to
live in peace who only want to assert
their basic human rights especially in
the areas of the ethnic nationalities
rape is rife it is used as a weapon
[Music]
welcome to the Dean show how you doing
in my next guest CJ wheeler Minh most of
you haven't heard the row hinga I didn't
know much about them I mean some things
just don't make the news you know you
got the signs when some fanatics some
crazy evil person goes and blows up
something and next thing you know the
whole world if the person have a certain
passport looks a certain way has a
certain color it seems like that gets
more news why is that the whole world
comes together stand for Paris stand for
this Stanford and we should stand
together as humanity against the evil
that's perpetrated by some evil phone
eggs but we got to keep it fair and
balanced people what about the rolling
United Nations and all of the
humanitarian the human rights
organizations have labeled this what's
going on to these people this is a
modern-day genocide women were all the
feminists everyone if you didn't know
you're not gonna have no excuse after
the show they're being raped and little
kids and are being drowned and men are
being an innocent people are being
tortured and it's madness it's hell on
earth so you can continue to stay
ignorant but after this you're not going
to have an excuse we can do our small
part to create awareness and I'm gonna
be helping to create this awareness with
my next guest CJ wheeler man on the Dean
show Avesta gated journalists colonists
and someone who's made also a turn for
the better someone hold still used to be
full of hate call himself somewhat of a
bigoted hate hate racist but he made a
change for the better there's hope for
everybody and this is what touched my
heart to have someone like him speaking
up on behalf of this persecuted people
so this is an exciting episode don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Dean show I got CJ
wheeler man how are you my friend thank
you for finding the time to be with us
you're a columnist for the middle east i
investigate investigate a journalist the
united nations the major human right
organizations have said that this is the
most persecuted minority group in the
world but the the question is where is
the world it seems like the
international community you know when
you most of us myself also and I'm
guilty of it we don't I mean you got to
kind of like go on your own
investigating people like yourself who
are brave enough to talk about this but
why is it that the global world is a
community tragic other tragic events
happen and people are out there and you
know it's at any time something like
this happens where an innocent group of
people or a person is is harmed and the
whole world comes together and pray for
Paris pray for this group but what about
the rowing from Bosnia for instance six
weeks warm what was gonna happen in
Tunisia we had thousands killed it
wasn't a total years like that Clinton
decided to intervene there we've seen in
Syria a bomber we need to read line in
the sand about half of the main Syrians
been killed since so when Muslim lives
are on the line even a lot of these you
know most members of the international
community have signed on to the UN
principle of
to protect which means that they a
sovereign state is unwilling or unable
or easy free what an unwanted security
risk to humans within their what
citizens will be NSA well the
international community has an
obligation to intervene and to protect
those lives but it's seemingly when it's
brown or Western it lives and you know
whether that's your window o Rwanda or
elsewhere
what's the community just sits on it's
on the international community just sits
on a ten even more since here is the
fact that not only is the Western
international community sitting on its
hands when it comes to the genocide
that's taking place in enemy anama as
they're actively proactively mobilizing
and backing and supporting the genocide
there you've got China which is fully
back to me and you've got in India which
says it back to me and my
counterterrorism operations in that
country when there is no terrorism
terrorist activity taking place in their
country that again is just a big leap
for India to to back the genocide
against them was the one point three
million Muslims who live there and
Israel continues to sell weapons to
China and neighboring Muslim majority
states have don't have the finances or
the resources to take care of the
refugee problem there so you know it's
not a case of doing nothing the Western
Lake Community community is doing
something they're actually helping the
place
tell me CJ let's back it up for the the
layman the person who is hearing about
this for the first time can you break it
down for us
what is that the part of the world this
has happened where this is happening and
what's happening how did this all start
a British colonial project and the
bridge they're a couple of hundred years
ago brought in Bengali laborers from
what is now Bangladesh and I use them
for you know basically civilian
infrastructure projects shape
international foreign labor but
basically and so
so what does that 1.3 million mussel
population that's here now I think in a
diaspora
I think population is closer to about 4
or 5 million they're basically the same
as people because Bangladesh no longer
consider the same to be Bangladeshis and
so they've always been scapegoat and
vilified there's basically four decades
of solid evidence of periodic mass
killings torture and expulsion
whenever political opportunists women in
a military winter have needed somebody
to vilify to you know help justify their
brutal and oppressive the regime will it
blend
ready go for it so they're big in apathy
political scapegoat for our memorial so
this is the row row hing go people and
this is in the country it's right next
to what China and India is that right
Myanmar yes and this is now people that
been there for for hundreds of years
yes and they've been persecuted for
these these hundreds of years and now is
is this something that's just coming to
light or it's it's gotten to to a whole
nother level twenty twelve so you know
me and my religion a transition period
from transitioning from basically a
quasi democratic site I mean you know
it's it's democracy I mean I'm Sookie is
basically just a figurehead to give the
military a friendly Democratic face
she's effectively powerless but that
doesn't pay her from the genocide that's
taking place in Yemen because she's used
the rhetoric the same kind of rhetoric
was seen Assad used to demonize Syrian
opposition as jihadis or terrorists or
Islamic extremist when the Rieger a file
from that I wanted a Syrian people with
far from that and so she's complicit in
the genocide even though she might be to
Palace she certainly completes
fueled the fire with what's happening is
so so the the crackdown really began in
about 2012 is during this transition
period and they've really stepped up in
Myanmar military has really stepped up
its operations to dispossessed to kill
to torture to lose and to it you know
it's spelled the ring of population I
mean now 300,000 and now internally just
place and you know with seeking refuge
on the Bangladesh border I think that
something like 80,000 move now
successfully cross the border illegally
into the Bangladesh or in one of the
three main refugee camps at but big red
majority had trapped there on the border
basically at the whims of the vampires
military so these are people that their
ancestors were on this land they were
born on the land so now there's specific
rights that have been taken away they
they're not allowed correct me if I'm
ever wrong they're not allowed to vote
they're restricted now to internment
camps is that right they're not they're
not allowed to have more than two
children like that I really commend you
because sometimes people like they jump
on it's a trend it's kind of like trendy
when you know there is something going
on in the world and you know celebrities
everybody will jump in and and they'll
bring light and they'll help to mitigate
you know a certain tragic situation
bring light to it and the media will
jump on and now you know people will
have to account but you're one of the
few I really commend you you're doing
some great work creating awareness on
this why don't we see more is it just
people are ignorant about it you know
is a selective outrage generating
machine and you know that the lives and
and plight of brand people particularly
Muslims in a part of the world where
most Americans are or many people in the
West identify on a map you know it
doesn't really disturb to me headlines
in Western media you know know was to
the media I mean if it wasn't for social
media you know many more wouldn't know
what's at what's what is taking place in
you know that I've seen a little bit of
which is encouraging what started off
making with Middle East I and Al Jazeera
and that's part of that list which sort
of cover
you know the apply for the crisis with
Muslims around the world I mean I even
sort of CNN cover the story for the
first time a couple of days ago so you
know noisy it's been created I think you
know enough people is paying attention
and our floor around there to be you
know headlines to be common and once you
have headlines and you have a debate
discussion from that camera you know
policy follows so hopefully policymakers
there's enough pressure on them or
growing pressure that they're unable to
see on their hands that ignore what's
happening let's talk about the the
tragedy of so many I'm hearing so many
innocent women are being raped
I mean systemically by the army you know
houses are big whole villages like five
hundred thousand at a time is this
correct several months ago and found it
basically passed up to about 50% of all
rebels and women had been subject to
some sort of sexual harassment at war
right I think one and three verifiably
raped so I mean you know children who
have been bayonetted while they're
breastfeeding from their mothers I mean
some of the atrocities that are coming
out of there I mean
matching or equal to anything that these
long stones that carried out in a
barracks or Syria but because its
borders extremes are sort of carrying
out these act of terrorism so you know
if this was some sort of Islamic
baccala around or the Islamic state or
our eyedropper ready and carrying out
his genocide in Myanmar and BMI was a
Muslim majority country and the
Buddhists were being persecuted you get
pretty sure this is a proxy it just
would it be again you know not only
getting more media attention but we'd
probably have us drones flying over
Miami and we'd have special forces
operative special operations forces
being dropped into the country panting
Daniel is talked about there's a an
extremist monk and we I mean we don't
obviously blame the the Buddhism for
these extremists but do we see as
Muslims I mean Muslims have become
nowadays professional condemned errs you
know we're always you know things that
have nothing to do with Islam or the
Muslims in America some some fringe
element they go and do something you
know evil and everyone is expected to
condemn we don't expect you know the
whole Buddhist world to come out and
condemn this but do you see do you see
do you see some some prominent like the
Dalai Lama and others coming out and
what's their stance on this military and
horrified by a rhetoric used by what
after use the the Buddhist extremist
monk who hits a 969 movement in a
country which is basically you know
that's he's soft the produce of his
Burma's have been loaded so I mean he
take these cues that he's inspiration
from from genocide or mass murderers so
you know again we do see the double
standard policy when it comes to you
know Muslims versus non-muslims you know
Muslim extremists those non Muslim
extremist nobody is coming out and
actually enjoy the Buddhist community to
condemn the rhetoric and the actions of
David him or his followers or militias
who take their inspiration from human in
that country but you know when a an
extremist arranged Muslim who's adopted
the perverted
the only devices carries an extremist
attacks somewhere on the streets of
Western European city suddenly we expect
one Quincy's boom wasn't due to condemn
his actions but when a Christian does
similar or a Buddhist similar you know
that expectation or obligation force
obligation is there we see the power you
strike a great example and you know I'm
from my parents I came over about 40
years ago from the former Yugoslavia
Bosnia the war that happened there and
the struggle that was going on there you
know against also something that many
people are ignorant to what was one of
the greatest genocides if not the great
identified after world war ii and you
have slobodan milosevic the war criminal
who was using this hate speech and
pumping up people and then we see the
the the evil effects of that and we see
the same thing what's happening here you
see these people in prominent positions
pumping up the people and the people
like sheep following along and then
dehumanizing we see what happens and you
can kind of contrast that then we have a
similar thing going on here with some
politicians in miami or even just in the
world in general with what happens a
dangerous thing when you start
dehumanizing people so they're less
humans and it's just like okay so their
their blood is not as valuable as the
next man's blood you know the negative
you know muslims or Arabs in movies are
always portrayed as suicide bombers or
or ruthless oil shapes so or some sort
of a slave rapist that you know we've
seen I mean all genocide start with
words but you know the genocides into a
place in Bosnia started with you know
several years of demonizing Muslims as
the other and as effective Serbian
values and Serbian conference everywhere
and you know that's what's happening
everywhere in the West I mean and that's
what is happening me Emma are these
bullets extremists portray reinga
Muslims has a trip to Myanmar
civilization is a threat to their values
and when you do that you can you portray
Islam for example as a threat to your
babies what you're saying is Muslims are
an object to be securitized we need to
secure Isis there because there are
danger that such security Poly's that's
from that logic the security security
policies are formulated and implemented
and so you know with you know increased
surveillance that means profiling that
means entrapment that means you know you
know the whole community's been
responsible you know a collective
responsibility which is a war crime so
well you know we've seen that me and I
we've seen elsewhere I mean it's it's
dangerous times I wrote a piece for the
Middle East on my column shortly after
the front was elected and the piece was
basically what happens in the United
States given fit the you know the 16
years of demonization and authorization
and dehumanization of Muslims in the
United States and you know somebody
who's been rewarded with that type of
rhetoric now the present what happens
the next day after the day after and
it's kind of strong big terrorist attack
takes place in nine states and it is
carried out by a Muslim I mean you've
already sent the the foundations for a
very civilian internment camps or worse
CJ tell me what what um inspired you and
Mo and motivated you to speak up for
this for this persecuted people yeah I
mean you know I mean noticed that
history but you know I for 10 years you
know which is the world's most populous
Muslim country in 2005 but we can say
in a fight early we can't buy country
despite a terrorist attack in a non-jew
bar on beach in Bali and we just got
about 16 people so I've been you know
enthralled in study terrorism and you
know I'm suddenly seeing my master's in
terrorism encounters at the moment it's
something that I've studied and surely
before I moved into academics a little
bit but when I initially decided trying
to understand the mindset of why people
would blow themselves out from types of
opinions with him I blamed religion and
I actually became in Blanding religion
and blaming Islam for those terrorist
attacks I myself became an anti-muslim
bigot and thankfully a couple of several
years after that I realized I'd been
wrong the big price I decided to study
Islam the deeper I decided to study
terrorism realized that thesis was
crudely wrong and evidently wrong and
you know and seemed so big trying to to
to to bring the world's attention to
what really does motivate and inspire
these these terrorist attacks in it so
you don't justices humiliation for
instance you now have the Salvation Army
I mean about Salvation Army or the
Huracan they're in in me and my Astra
isn't known I mean here's a small
militia group who have been accused of
carrying out terrorist attacks there me
and my response or in self-defense of
other Auriga but their self defend their
anger Muslim but you know we in the West
once they kill a maybe a couple of
Burmese military officials will you know
you'll see no reason when saying gonna
be radicalized by jihadists ideology
Islam is radicalized these people when
really they're just being on the
receiving end of themselves in there
they are defending their communities so
you're familiar now you're really
intensively studying you know advocating
for the study academic research on
terrorism Robert Pape and you of the
University of Chicago and others they've
done studies funded by the Pentagon that
people aren't how come they don't have
on CNN people like him people like
yourself
who
are bringing to light these these facts
you know most of the people they're
trying to make it seem like Islam is the
root of this terrorism but when
intellectuals like yourselves academics
when when you look at the the facts
that's totally the antithesis of the
truth or carried out by Isis and you'll
have the usual party of Congo line of
Islamophobes you know shameless
opportunist let my kid know was who will
posit that it's you know it's not it's
not blowback from with some foreign
policy it's not you know a perverted
ideology it's not you know social
structures and social injustice is there
are the root of this instead we talk
about radicalization and we're talking
about radical Islam and I mean
utilisation radicalization that word was
you know purposely what return was
purposely injected into public discourse
by the Bush administration because the
Bush administration was in no mood to
talk about that you know the root causes
all the reasons why how quadrant bin
Laden carried out the 9/11 attacks they
did not want to have a discussion about
why our military bases were in the Holy
Land they didn't want to have a
discussion about how we you know handle
the palestinian-israeli conflict in an
uneven manner they didn't want to talk
about why we you know common and it
supports some of the most kissed by the
oppressive regimes in the Middle East
and elsewhere instead they wanted to
shift blame away from anything that
might make them culpable and shifted
entirely to you know when other people's
culture what can the average person do
they tune in and they're they're hearing
this you know the heart gravitates
towards wanted to do something good for
their fellow man and they see like okay
you know this could be my family
tomorrow how can I help out what can I
do now they're listening what what I'm
powerless like what give me some advice
what can I do to make a difference a
positive difference
where you are if you're a Democratic
Party like you I was like here in United
States and you know make noise noise
attracts of me meteors you know is it's
always attracted to bright shiny things
and you know there's nothing more to
bright and shiny for the media when it
is a lot of public noise and stirring
and that's really you know the noise
that's being paraded on social media
about what's happening in Myanmar is
arisen you're now seeing you know but a
process of me am I might explain to the
CNN if it makes its way onto the CNN
then policymakers are gonna start paying
attention because they constituents
about paying attention so I mean you
know even roster things you know sign
petitions online petitions petitions
call an email your your Commodus Minori
to send them let them know that you know
it's intolerable that the United States
is sitting on their hands doing nothing
while you know a whole people being so
no I mean these things through create
action but if we if we just you know
maintain you know silent yeah right and
you know not no actual follow from that
I really commend you again as I've said
you know your your voice has been strong
on this and I hope many will will go
ahead and follow in your footsteps to
help create awareness in this and and
see the the truth which is kind of
distorted in in in in out there but you
bring in light to it really is going to
help a lot of people we're trying to do
our part and I really commend you thank
you so much for finding the time to
speak with us here on the D so I really
appreciate that I'm sure our viewers do
also thank and there you have it thank
you for tuning in doing our small part
to create some awareness now everybody
if everybody does their a small part
send a tweet a share do something to get
this information out and that's how we
can make a change we can make a
difference
instead of tweeting something that is of
no benefit this actually has some
benefit to make as our guest CJ wheeler
Minh was saying make some noise make
some noise so people can hear the voice
of
the persecuted who are out there
suffering mass murder they're being
tortured women raped you can close your
eyes but you heard this so you heard it
now you can go ahead and do your small
part bring the humanists out and this is
what really amazed me amazes me about
people like CJ wheeler men who were on
one side on the hate side on the hate
train and they're there their hearts are
become coming alive and now you see
people like this who were once
propagating on the hate machine
anti-muslim anti Islam and now they're
speaking he's speaking on behalf of this
persecuted minority I commend you CJ
make sure we hook up when you're in
Chicago I really admire you taking a
stand for this persecuted minority and
letting your voice be loud and clear on
this and making a shift to change for
the for the difference speaking the
truth on these matters very important
you've brought some great things to
light and thank you everybody for tuning
in now do your part share sharing is
caring get the information out thank you
very much see you next time hearing the
details of scribe if you haven't already
until then thank you peace be with you
Islamic
you